una ciudad en ruinas Y todavía un campo
de batalla tras meses de combates las
fuerzas ucranianas siguen resistiendo en
bahamut en circunstancias cada vez más
difíciles
el enemigo que nos asalta está bien
preparado no son simples convictos como
algunos dicen son unidades que saben lo
que hacen
no debemos subestimar a nuestro oponente
Quién ha reconocido que está perdiendo
terreno en la disputada ciudad situada
en la provincia oriental de danés el
kremlin afirmó que está logrando avances
con lo que denomina grupos de asalto un
término que suele emplearse para
referirse a las tropas del grupo militar
Mercenario Wagner
los destacamentos de asalto liberaron
tres cuarteles en la parte occidental de
la ciudad de bakmuth las tropas
aerotransportadas bloquearon el enemigo
en los flancos y apoyaron a los
destacamentos de asalto para hacerse con
el control de la ciudad pese a su escaso
valor estratégico evidentemente
considera que Back mood es un peldaño
clave para conquistar la provincia de
daniesk que se anexionó ilegalmente el
verano pasado pese a no tener pleno
control sobre ella en la cercana ciudad
de chasis ya los voluntarios distribuyen
ayuda humanitaria e intentan en vano
convencer a los civiles que quedan de
que evacúen en caso de que caiga bakmuth
y los rusos avancen hacia el oeste
han vivido aquí toda su vida conocen
cada olla y sartén que compraron es su
propiedad saben que marcharse
significaría perderlo todo
como Ucrania preparando una
contraofensiva es probable que los
combates en la región se intensifiquen
en los próximos meses